pub
[Musique]
l'antigel
un antigel vous avez peut-être jamais
entendu parler si je voulais en maître
aujourd'hui trop tard ces tenues par
chez vous il a fait moins 11
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
commander les pièces si vous y tenez
parce que avec la main d'oeuvre
je serais vous je laisserais tomber
normand vous pouvez pas c'est vrai je
vous dis j'ai pas des pièces
ces éléments devront monter là haut ça
le problème
les enfants qui font des kilomètres à
pied pour venir à l'école si je suis pas
là demain matin pour les accueillir non
c'est impossible
il aurait bien une solution oui
connaissez la valériane
l'infirmière oui j'ai enfin vu je suis
tout nouveau dans la région ariane passe
tous les jours un peu près cet or si on
va la gaieté
[Musique]
ouais
vraiment noël ça vous ennuie pas j'ai
bien compris il s'agit d'une opération
de secours en montagne pour quelque
sorte oui ça rentre parfaitement dans
les attributions merci
le bout
ainsi vous les avez vues dans ce café
dans un mais non mais non plus chaque
fois je voulais m'arrêter à cause de
cette curieuse enseigne jamais le temps
pour les gens du pays c'est un endroit
où on ne va pas retirer
pourquoi allez savoir fait comme ça vous
avez encore mal non dentiste m'a fait un
pansement
je sens plus rien qu'une vous pas très
agréable dans la bouche pour dire du
coup de girofle noix bon pastis il n'en
sera plus question à condition qu'on
veut bien nous servir à quelqu'un
on peut être enlevé dans un café
fantômes ne parviendrait pas à me faire
peur avec vos histoires sont pas
musulmans sont celles de bradbury borgas
et autres auteurs de science fiction
j'espère que vous ne traumatise et par
les enfants avec ces balivernes les
enfants de quoi aucun danger sont très
en avance sur nous sont plaqués avec eux
qu'est-ce que vous prenez un café patron
s'il vous plaît un café et un pastis et
bien pour vous l'amateur de mystère
voici on a une énigme irrésolue qu'elle
est ni lors de ce café la baline ceci
n'était qu'un tout petit mystère nous en
avons beaucoup d'autres en réserve et
beaucoup plus déconcertant vous avez
malgré mon peu de vous pour ce genre de
récit je sais tout de même qu'il en
existe une littérature très abondants
cette fois il s'agit pas de littérature
mais d'un phénomène dont j'ai été le
témoin bon à savoir vous commencez par
vous moquer c'est pas une attitude
scientifiquement objective
excusez moi monsieur la terre voilà
plusieurs soirs de suite en passant par
le col juste au moment d'aborder l'autre
versant j'ai remarqué un phénomène tout
à fait étrange dans une prairie à droite
de la route y sommes merci
continuez je vous écoute lui aussi est
alors je pense un jeu vous avez vu ses
yeux la marine à 12 cents mètres
d'altitude
vous trouvez ça normal êtes vous sûr que
votre dentiste n'est pas un peu trop
forcé la dose de calmants je me sens
tout à fait lui aurait dû éviter de
boire glacé dans votre casse un départ
canon et sans doute raison alors en haut
du col
juste au moment d'aborder l'autre
versant dans une prairie à droite de la
route
je situe parfaitement l'endroit et avez
vous vu et bien j'ai vu ne sauriez pas
j'ai vu par une fois dit deux fois les
plusieurs soirs de suite j'ai vu
[Musique]
ans
mais je vous dois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça votre phénomène extraordinaire
oui on dirait comme une porte de lumière
tournait pas il vous est jamais venu à
l'idée que ça pouvait être le reflet des
phares sur la neige attendez attendez
éteignez vos phares alors supposer
s'ils posaient que de l'autre côté une
voiture se soit arrêtée pleins phares
comme nous venons de le faire à
l'instinct de l'autre côté la route
passe en contrebas
puis il ya des arbres il doit y avoir
une explication
il est impossible qu'il n'y en ait pas
une je ne crois pas aux mystères
publicitaires se moque bien de ce que
vous pouvez penser de lui n'a pas besoin
de vous pour exister 600 crédulité plus
de mystère alors voir de plus près ce
n'est pas bien loin
c'est que c'est vrai m pas montagnard et
ses quelques pas dans la neige vous
effraie poursuivre ou non mais alors
c'est la réalité qui vous fait peur
c'est entendu allons-y
l épave
vous enseignez à l'est par on n'y allait
pas n'y allez pas y aller par marianne
non où êtes vous répondez
où êtes vous
vous m'entendez répondait aux eaux où
êtes-vous organes ariane ariane ariane
baye
rien
qu'est ce que cette fois
ap
crise de nerfs ne reste jamais rien
parce que je dis à mes malades
elle m'a fait du bien faire
j'ai crié aussi
mais ça n'a pas marché
quand j'étais petite fille que je
faisais des cauchemars j'ai crié très
fort pour me réveiller je suis vous bien
réveillé
et rien n'a changé
théo
vous appelez bien théo n'est ce pas
qu'est ce que tout cela signifie
on sait
comment sommes-nous arrivés jusqu'ici
et pourquoi
il doit y avoir une explication il est
impossible qu'il n'y aurait pas une
c'est ce que vous avez dit à propos d'un
porte de lumière je n'ai rien oublié
[Musique]
mais la neige et le vent ni cette lueur
éblouissante et surtout pas vos créé
pour souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
juste maintenant vous avez franchi cette
porte
non
non plus
et j'ai eu la neige le vent
la lumière est puissant
se révèle ici nous sommes depuis vous
avez leur nom y'a plus d'heures
- chaussures sont sèches
aucun touché à la main
peillon il faut sortir d'ici bon
passons une inspection systématique de
notre de notre prison plutôt de notre
cellule sans négliger un centimètre
carré
vous êtes d'un calme bien obligé vous
étiez si peu tout à leur show oui
si nous commencions par l'ailé c'est
machin sur lequel nous avons dormi et
fort bien dormi tout au moins ce qui me
concerne j'ai très bien dormi également
et sans la surprise de me retrouver ici
non pas long que voulez vous si dont
nous avons bien dormi c'est que cette
pièce relativement petit tu es
correctement et aéré à défaut de portes
ou des fenêtres invisible il existe
obligatoirement un système d'aération
où
[Musique]
vous devriez faire comme en gagnant du
temps
faut bien faire quelque chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous n'aurions jamais dû aller boire un
verre dans ce café ce n'est peut-être
pas un indice une simple coïncidence
ni gentils et le vent chaud venu de se
baser du g20 veulent s inès paye mais
les bains tous ses meilleurs en toute
autonomie terrain cette vente est bel et
bien cet indice s'élevait
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir cela
veut dire veut dire que c'est votre
indice dax en voilà bien et celui que et
que s'il vous manque quoi que ce soit
vous pouvez faire appel à moi nous
voulons sortir
vous avez compris nous voulons sortir
sortir mes sorties ressortir cet article
sortir n'est pas une nécessité vitale
pas une nécessité vitale pour l'eau si
nous voulons aller dehors comprenez d'or
deux hommes me tarde à 2 or est un mot
qui n'a aucune signification
mais si pour nous deux or cela signifie
la liberté
le mot liberté vaut quelque chose pour
vous liberté liberté liberté oui vous
devez savoir ce que cela signifie qu'ils
libèrent des libertés même de toute
votre vie vous n'avez jamais été aussi
libres jeunes est aussi libre
non à rien non non pas pourquoi là c'est
moi non vous m'avez appris à me méfier
des portes
il est des seuils périlleux à franchir
attendez
maintenant allons-y
[Musique]
oh
et
mais
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si dément vous ne nous apprenez rien
décidément vous ne nous apprenait rien
nous n'y arriverons jamais comme ça
chaque carrefour offre deux directions
possibles
ses parents nous le premier sorti de
livres à l'autre j'aime beaucoup cette
solution avez-vous mieux à proposer
alors
alors je sais pas
et ces gens
si vous voulez
je prends à gauche
vous irez à droite inutile de courir
marchand calmement
regarde oui
on voit rien et bonne chance au gardien
et bonne chance
tous les quinze pages écrire à votre nom
tant que je vous entendre et je vous
répondrai au revoir rien
ariane
tél
oriane
[Musique]
décidément vous ne nous apprenait rien à
rien
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
[Musique]
vous ne nous apprenait rien qu'avez vous
fait de cette liberté que vous réclamiez
vous ne nous avait pas donné la liberté
c'était un piège l'exercice de la
liberté est plein de pièges c'était à
vous de les éviter
non vous ne nous avait rien appris que
pouvions nous faire puisque le jeu était
faussé comme je vous sais rien
on discute pas
cette inutile la résignation n'est pas
une solution
il n'y a qu'une solution pour les rats
enfermé dans un avis rent de laboratoire
2006 mais aussi intelligent que les
savants qui les observent
je refuse la condition de gras vous
n'avez pas l'accepter ou la refuser ce
qui vous observe donc que faire de votre
avis ce qui les intéresse c'est votre
comportement à l'intérieur du labyrinthe
non non ce n'est pas possible nous pas
nous prendre dans un labyrinthe
si bien sûr alors
il doit y avoir une explication puis il
est impossible qu'il n'y ait pas
vous voyez on n'en est même plus finir
votre phrase votre phrase favorite
[Musique]
regarde rester calmes mesurer
l'intensité de notre espoir ou de notre
désespoir que sans doute également
partie de l'expérience
montrons notre supériorité sur les rats
de laboratoire eux ne savent pas qu'ils
sont soumis à une expérience nous si st
gall
je suis calme
je vous l'avais promis je tiens mes
promesses
je vais pas m'y remettre bravo du moment
vous avez besoin d'un miroir c'est que
le moral est meilleur
vous n'avez pas répondu
j'ai laissé mon sac dans la voiture et
je n'ai pas de miroir sur moi moi non
plus malheureusement
peut-être que dans le boîtier de ma
montre je ne vois rien qu'une vague
silhouette assez lointaine décidément
ici les montres ne sont d'aucune utilité
comment suis-je très belle et parce que
je vous demandais je croyais
c'est vous qui avez mis cette musique
nous
[Musique]
aucun de ces boutons t'as plus récemment
revenue c'est bon
[Musique]
et aussi me surprend chez vous c'est
comment dirais-je voutré désinvolture la
désinvolture
si vous voyez un courrier projet était
seul dans ses couloirs une parleriez pas
de désinvolture
quand vous êtes avec moi vous semblez
toujours considéré ce qui nous arrive
comme parfaitement naturel quand on est
deux on se sent plus fort et je puise en
vous le courage de vous rassurer il est
sur la terre des millions et des
millions de guipel d'humains qui ont
fait l'expérience
sans une telle des brochures mise en
scène vous avez même le courage de
plaisanterie s'ils n'ont pas de temps en
temps nous reste plus qu'à nous et en
attendant la main j'y pense
[Musique]
continuez à plaisanter vous parler
sérieusement
elles n'ont pas regardé mois la barre à
pousser et à la puis cela prouve qu'il
ya plusieurs heures nous sommes ici 24
heures peut-être vous souvenez-vous des
derniers mots que je vous ai dit en
sortant ce qu'a fait juste avant de
monter dans votre voiture
wills était bouleversante poésie vous
avez dit je crève de faim exact
si j'en crois ma barbe nous sommes ici
depuis 24 heures nous n'avons ni bu ni
mangé je n'ai pas fait
[Musique]
c'est vrai
moi non plus
je comprends maintenant ce que voulait
dire cette voie avec jamais vous n'avez
été aussi libre cela signifiait que nous
étions des livres et de toutes ces
servitudes humaine sauf le sommeil je ne
sais si c'est cette musique mais je ne
soit envahie par une résistible envie de
dormir
ils ont jugé sans doute qu'il était trop
dangereux depuis des êtres humains de
sommeil une part tellement pour nous
reposer le même traitement qu'elle
supprimait la faim et la soif aurait pu
les fatiguer nos muscles mais parce que
l'homme est un animal qui a besoin de
rêver
[Musique]
et aussi si ça ne vous ennuie page
j'aimerais bien ne pas dormir ici jambes
et ça va les gars n'ont pas eu cette
pièce n'est pas bien grande je sais bien
mais maintenant que je vous ai retrouvé
je ne voudrais pas vous perdre puis-je
dormir près de vous
oui probablement
[Musique]
et tu as toi cette chanson toi
l'auvergnat qui sans façons m'as donné
quatre voies pendant qu'au sein des
villes plus étroit toi qui rit
les gens viennent intentions m'appelle
terre la porte au nez
ce n'était rien qu'un feu de bois
mais il m'avait chauffer le corps est
dans mon âme ils brûlent encore
le programme t'emportera qu'il te
conduise à travers ciel au maire
est à toi cette chanson toi une thèse
qui sans façons m'as donné quatre bouts
de pain quand dans ma vie il faisait fin
toi qui m'ouvre est notamment quand tu
lis croquante et les croquants tous les
gens bien intentionnés s'amusait à me
voir je dis mais c'est par ici
elles sont plutôt que c'est par là venez
avec moi il ne faut plus nous tout est
mort dans l'ordre à kiel devant 2000 à
messieurs et a6 et aux grands pieds je
vous avez raison granger retournant
lorsque les gendarmes ont pris toi qui
n'a pas applaudi tant les trocante 0
quand tous les gens bien intentionnés
riez de me voir l'avenir sereinement
quand peu de vienne mais il m'a
réchauffé le corps est dans mon âme ils
pullulent encore roman porte qu'il te
conduise à travers ciel au père éternel
vous n'aimez pas cette chanson 6
beaucoup et votre compagne laine
également mais mais oui je vous assure
alors pourquoi tremblay vous est ce mon
aspect physique qui en est la cause
non non n'est ce pas non bien sûr
nous sommes surpris voilà tout nous
avions entendu chanter dehors enfin je
veux dire dans les couloirs et nous vous
trouvons ici alors nous sommes surpris
c'est cela nous sommes surpris
c'était un test disait aussi voyez rien
c'était un test un de plus il ya si
longtemps que je n'avais pas chanté
cette chanson si longtemps des siècles
je voulais voir si je ne l'avais pas
oublié les paroles je n'ai rien oublié
je n'oublie jamais rien le contraire
serait étonnant
enfin je veux dire alarmant et bien
maintenant voilà tout à fait rassuré
mais vous pas vous continuez à avoir
peur non pourquoi aurions nous peur nous
n'avons rien à lui reprocher vous avez
peur je le sens vous ne trouvez vous pas
n'êtes vous pas ici chez vous non
monsieur
nous ne sommes pas chez nous et vous le
savez bien
moi je sais surtout tout ce que je ne
sais pas entrée dont nous serons mieux
pour poser
[Applaudissements]
bien vous me dites que vous n'êtes pas
ici chez vous c'est donc que vous
prétendez venir d'affaires naturellement
c'est une question stupide c'est un coup
de questions stupides que l'on avance
sur le chemin de la connaissance la
véritable stupidité consiste à ne pas se
les poser vous êtes donc bien certains
de venir d'ailleurs
oui naturellement n'employez pas
constamment cet adverbe qui ne veut rien
dire
savez vous vous êtes alors comment
pouvez-vous prétendre venir d'ailleurs
non ne me répondait pas je voulais
simplement vous montrer à quelle
surprise on s'expose quand on prétend
raisonner logiquement la sagesse
recommande de connaître ses propres
limites
monsieur je ne sais pas qui vous êtes et
je ne veux pas le savoir
j'ignore également quel but vous
poursuivi en nous transformant en la de
laboratoire
nous allons couru à travers votre
labyrinthe et vous nous avez déclaré que
nous ne vous apprenions rien alors
puisque nous ne servons à rien laissez
nous partir
vous n'avez aucun intérêt à nous garder
prisonniers puisque nous servons à rien
à rien vous l'avez dit ne parle pas
c'est médecine il y à des siècles que je
n'avais pas chanté
il ya des siècles que je ne vais pas
parler programmant les questions une à
une voulez-vous première question vous
ne vous sentez pas à votre réussite
et vous voudriez en sortir c'est bien
cela c'est cela monsieur n'a rien à
faire dans ce monde qui n'est pas le
nôtre où nous prend pour des rats ne
sommes pas des rats ariane monsieur vous
a demandé de parler enfin ça va j'ai
compris vous voulez vous en aller oui
monsieur
oh oui 20e question vous estimez que
cette décision dépend mois mais bruits
naturels naturellement les spas et bien
non qui croyez vous que je sois
je suis un robot et parce que les
cristaux de mon cerveau électronique ont
été sensibilisés au bout que la mémoire
contient des millions de poèmes ce d'ici
me considère comme un objet inoffensif
je suis l'idiot dû village on perd mais
que je me promène à ma guise dans le
labyrinthe mais il est certaines lois
que je ne dois pas enfreindre
tenez vous allez vous en rendre compte
il s'immisce nsn c'est mon nom ici me
sène me donnez vous l'autorisation de
rester encore quelques instants dans cet
albert hall quelques instants seulement
pour les deux sujets ça va être l'heure
de se reposer bien je ne resterait que
quelques instants pour les deux sujets
ça va être l'heure du repos compris
mycènes compris ça va être l'heure mais
quelle heure est il le nom cela devrait
vous suffire
permettez moi avant de me retirer je
voudrais voir boma
merci
avez vous déjà fait l'amour ensemble non
et puisque vous prétendez venir
d'ailleurs d'où prétendez-vous venir du
col du bonnet vert col du bonnet vert un
petit col dans les montagnes de haute
provence alpes de haute provence
oui anciennement département des bases
alpes est actuellement département des
alpes-de-haute-provence
mais sur quelle planète sur quelle
planète même mais sur la terre
impossible non dans la terre
mathématiquement et scientifiquement
c'est rigoureusement impossible mais il
d'ailleurs
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien dormi oui on va regarder vos
comme ça qu'est ce que j'ai vous êtes
rasé de frais ça c'est vrai et emad ans
c'est comme si j'avais jamais eu mal
servez vous trouvez tout est relatif
bien sûr crevé pas que j'oublie cet
endroit étrange nous sommes prisonniers
pour tout avouer j'ai toujours peur je
suis toujours angoissé et terrorisé même
par instants seulement
c'est comme pour ma dans mon corps ne
participe pas à cette peur cette
angoisse à cette erreur je ne ressens
aucun malaise physique et vous je suis
bien obligé de reconnaître que
physiquement je me sens reposer ça se
voit j'étais arrivé du labyrinthe
moi non plus d'ailleurs je ne souviens
pas d'un rêve en particulier c'était la
vie de tous les jours mes enfants tant
dans la petite salle de classe se
débarrassant de leurs manteaux humide de
neige
le silence qui s'établit assez
péniblement et la leçon qui commence
aucun détail insolite ou extravagants à
quoi ça reconnaît un rêve si tout de
même
je n'avais encore jamais fait cette
leçon d'histoire et dans l'année
scolaire la leçon histoire est un repère
chronologique indiscutable cette leçon
je n'avais pas encore fait
pourtant les questions des enfants ne
surprenait pas je les attendais je
vivais un épisode assez vous avez rêvé
d'une classe que vous avez déjà fait
possible c'est la première année que
j'enseigne et vous marianne avez vous
rêvé
[Musique]
il faut faire quelque chose
malheureusement je crains que nous ne
puissions pas faire grand chose tant que
nous sommes sous l'effet de cette drogue
quelle drogue en fait vous n'avez vous
pas compris qu'il existe une explication
logique et cohérente à tout ce qui nous
arrive sans avoir recours à tous ses
fantasmes dans sa boîte votre
imagination
tout à l'heure je rêvais mais maintenant
je suis éveillé quand je faisais payer
j'aime bien avoir les deux pieds sur la
terre les pieds sur terre
laissez moi rire regardez un peu la
nature du sol sur lequel vous marchez
examiner le temps chez vous gratter le
avec vos ongles et semur semur son
ouverture n'est-il pas virer est lui
aussi il est pas le produit d'une drogue
hallucinogène
le robot la traverse est certes mais il
a des pouvoirs que je ne possède pas et
quand j'ai voulu l'unité le centquatre
si violent que je me suis retrouvé à
terre qu'on vous dit
vous m'avez aidé à me relever et la
lumière
la lumière qui éclaire cette pièce et
les couloirs
quelle est la source de cette lumière et
ça ça aussi c'est une hallucination
[Musique]
y en ait plus
alors
laissez moi j'ai tiqué quand les
premiers à caravelle pour tous chers le
rivage des indes occidentales et que la
nouvelle on fit connu dans l'intérieur
du pays
il se trouvera certainement de 13
illustres savants aztèques ou maya pour
déclaré gravement qu'il s'agissait d'un
bien curieux phénomène d'hallucination
collective
théo soyez gentils taisez vous
et pourtant
même description des moyens employés
pour sortir d'ici
non pas recommencer l'expérience de
l'amiante
pourquoi pas nous avons peut-être manqué
de perspicacité la première fois de même
que nous n'avons pas poser toutes les
questions qu'il fallait que désirez-vous
je vous écoute
qui êtes vous je ne veux pas répondre
vous ne voulez pas répondre je veux bien
répondre mais je ne veux pas pourquoi
seraient obligés d'envoyer des eaux des
concepts des formules dans le sens nous
échappe complètement complète où vous
voulez dire que nous sommes par rapport
à vous dans la situation d'un rat de
laboratoire vis-à-vis d'un salon images
à peu près exact
quoique quoique la distance soit encore
plus grande
pourquoi faites vous cette expérience
parce que notre soleil vint mourir
avez vous compris notre soleil 20 ou
mourir
c'est pour remédier à cette catastrophe
que vous faites cette expérience avec
nous exact
tout à fait exact
les temps sont proches le soleil va
mourir
faut-il retourner dans le labyrinthe
vous êtes libres libres d'y retourner ou
de ne pas y retourner
avons nous poser des questions
intéressantes non stupéfiants de
banalités décidément vous ne nous
apprenez
[Musique]
ce repos vous at il été profitable qui
êtes vous que voulez vous parmi les
premiers éléments qui ont été incorporés
à ma mémoire qui elle est infaillible se
trouvait cette notion que je vérifie
encore aujourd'hui à savoir que vous les
êtres de chair et de sang ne posséder
qu'une mémoire infirme infantile est
ridicule
je vous ai dit qu'ils jettent est ce que
j'étais
michel le robot vous ne vous en souvenez
déjà plus non je n'avais pas oublié
votre nom ni sun avec un y je suppose et
votre prétention à n'être qu'un robot je
ne me laisserai pas enfermer dans ce
monde où des membres
vous voulez le faire devenir folle vous
n'y parviendrez pas c'est pourquoi je
vous demande de jeter bas le masque et
de nous dire qui vous êtes et ce que
vous voulez réellement si ce mot a
encore un sens pour vous n'essayez pas
de vous cacher derrière des symboles
grotesque il disait d'une phraséologie
de bazar comme l'autre avec son soleil
qui va mourir
répondez sans tricher aux questions que
je vous ai posé si vous en êtes capables
ses rayons les questions si vous le
voulez bien
c'est vrai c'est un robot et votre
cerveau agit à la manière d'un
ordinateur qui classe des tiges perforé
le système est infiniment plus
perfectionnés mais le principe reste le
même
alors pour le soleil qui va mourir
c'est scientifiquement exact mais cette
parenthèse nous mènerait trop loin or
vont exiger des réponses précises
oui je m'appelle miss aisne
pourquoi cela nous conduirait trop loin
également on peut toujours triché sur un
nom êtes vous d'accord sur ce point
oui je suis un robot je comprends que ma
parole ne suffit pas regardez et vous
aussi approché regarder toucher
entendez vous battre en choeur non
n'est ce pas un ballon touché n'ayez pas
peur avec vos cinq doigts le matériel f1
mais non fragiles
il a été conçu pour durer et des siècles
et des siècles
vous n'êtes pas convaincu enlevez cette
pièce si vous le voulez non non celle ci
d'abord autant que possible
[Musique]
sept autres maintenant n'ayez pas peur
tirer sur le fil
je le remettrai à l'on sait moins
répugnant que d'ouvrir le corps d'un
être vivant encore continuer n'osais pas
pourquoi écarter les fils maintenant
doucement si possible et dites moi si un
être de chair et de sang pourrait se
dissimuler parmi ses fils ses aciers
spéciaux c'est quartz et siliconée ces
cristaux
vous en avez assez vu pouvez-vous me
reconstitué à présent vous nous avez dit
que vous pouviez vous promener librement
dans le labyrinthe
je reste des siècles s'en sortir et puis
subitement je ne sais pas pourquoi je me
promène mais vous êtes libre d'aller où
bon vous semble
absolument au début ils ont voulu faire
des expériences avec moi ils ont très
vite abandonné mon cerveau conditionné
pour être sensible au bo leur a paru
inutilisable pour eux la poésie n'est
pas une solution
les imbéciles j'étais irrécupérable vous
connaissez donc bien le labyrinthe et
même au delà
c'est vrai je ne vous ai jamais menti ce
n'est pas comme vous non plus nous
n'avons jamais menti si en prétendant
venir de la terre non c'est faux
la terre nous y sommes
du moins ce qu'il en reste après la
grande explosion de l'ensemble d'après
l'ancien calendrier l'an 100 milles
après jésus-christ je n'ai jamais pu
m'habituer à compter autrement
écoutez miss aisne toute cette
discussion chronologique et sans intérêt
pour l'instant j'ai une question à vous
poser une seule
êtes vous disposé à nous aider
je viens de le prouver comprends pas
grâce à cette pièce
notre conversation restera confidentiel
il ne nous entendra pas mais faites vite
nous sommes entrés ici par une sorte de
porte de lumière votre planète comporte
une atmosphère la même qu'ici c'est
évitant ce qui lui a été provoquée par
l'échauffement du chalut qu'elle salue
l'appareillage qui sert à pêcher les
spécimens vivants sur les autres
planètes continue et fatigue mais
pourriez vous nous indiquer l'endroit
d'où on lance ce chat lui vous voulez
dire le saint louis voyez évidemment
mais cela ne vous annoncerai pas à grand
chose
ne craignez rien ils sont inoffensifs
idiot mais parfaitement inoffensif pas
tellement que sa miss elle me sun oui si
vous recommencez
vous serez privé de l'iut à non je suis
le ténébreux où le vin l'inconsolé le
prince d'aquitaine à la tour aboli
ma seule étoile est morte et mon lutte
constellé porte le soleil noir de la
mélancolie
suis-je amour phébus l'usinier oublions
mon front et rouge encore du baiser de
la reine
j'ai rêvé dans la grotte où nagent la
sirène et j'ai deux fois vainqueur
traverser la cayron modulant tour à tour
sur la lyre d'orphée les soupirs de la
sainte et les cris de la fée
mais ça ne vous emmène tiff ne vous en
faites pas rien de grave
nous nous reverrons est plutôt comme on
le pensait
[Applaudissements]
venez avec moi je veux bien mais où le
sas existe nous allons retrouver
il est quantité de couloir que nous
n'avons pas visité nous trouverons nous
ne passerons pas à travers les murs
comme miss aisne ne trouveront données
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
mais
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une peau de lumière
anais
[Musique]
telle est non violent at il ajouté vous
est il arrivé
rien c'est à cause de nous n'est ce pas
non vous nous disiez tout à l'heure que
il suffit de passer le pont s'est tout
de suite la vente une île
décidément vous ne nous apprend rien
[Musique]
vous persistez à prétendre que vous
venez de la planète terre ici vous
pouvez parler nous sommes loin des
oreilles indiscrètes
alors nous venons de la terre nous vous
l'avons déjà dit 100 montre ici en
franchissant une porte de lumière où
l'avait déjà dit également
je connais le fonctionnement du saas et
du chalut ce n'est pas ce qui
m'intéresse ce que je veux savoir c'est
si votre planète d'origine est vraiment
la terre voulez-vous que je vous réponde
diverses administrations ont déjà posé
des questions aussi stupide qu'un
discrète mais jusqu'à ce jour personne
avait mis ma qualité de terriers en
doute
ne perdons pas de temps voulez vous
ces étoiles doivent vous être familier
vous en reconnaîtrez bien quelques unes
mon beau navire au ma mémoire
avons nous assez navigué dans une eau de
mauvaise abois avons nous assez divaguer
de la belle au bois triste soir voie
lactée aux soeurs lumineuse des blancs
ruisseau de cannes en et décor blanc des
amoureuses nageurs mort suivront nous
dahan ton cours vers d'autres nébuleuse
on ne dit rien guillaume apollinaire
certes mais les étoiles nommément une ou
deux ça me suffira j'en connais aucune
donc une pâle verdict vous les
connaissiez en inventant des noms ont
besoin je n'en connais pas là le ciel de
la terre et je le dis
cette carte du ciel vous dit quelque
chose oui nature bien sûr est à bout à
moi aussi
pouvez vous me nommez quelques étoiles
juste quelques unes théo vous êtes plus
qualifiés que moi ma connaissance sont
guère étendu en cette matière mais si je
vous désigne la grande ourse
ici la petite tous là qu'on peut appeler
grand chariot et petits chariots si vous
préférez sans oublier l'étoile polaire
si utile quand on se perd en forêt serez
vous satisfait
êtes vous convaincu à présent que nous
venons vient de la planète terre il est
toujours très difficile de modifier des
habitudes de pensée surtout comment ces
habitudes sont vieilles de plusieurs
siècles
que dis-je plusieurs siècles plusieurs
centaines de millénaires dans le cerveau
les circuits électroniques fonctionne
automatiquement avant même d'être
sollicité vous qui employés si
facilement et si légèrement le mot
naturellement sachez qu'une des grandes
lois de la nature et la paresse c'est ce
que les spécialistes appellent le
principe de maupertuis on va où plus
facile qu'on soit cailloux plants
animals ou robot est le plus facile pour
vous consisterait à nier que nous venons
de la terre oui puisqu'en principe c'est
mathématiquement impossible du moins
avec tout ce que j'ai appris jusqu'à ce
jour et j'ai suivi tous les stages de
recyclage depuis des millénaires
j'ai abandonné éliminés chaque fois les
circuits usées corps au départ les
impuretés du temps si vous pouviez
savoir tout ce qui se passe
n'oubliez pas que vous avez promis de
nous mener jusqu'à la sortie un dernier
test voulez vous encore plus
indispensable pour moi que pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
que pensez-vous de souci je suis joueur
tout à fait moyen
si je suis capable de vous dire combien
de coups les noirs obtiendront l'échec
et mat
vous connaissez ce jour oui
personnellement bien que je sois de
force tout à fait moyenne je ferai pas
laisser ma tour sur cette case c'est pas
votre avis je ne sais pas
vous voyez une autre solution
non puisque je vous ai dit que je ne
sais pas vous savez pas joué ont peu à
peu près tout à prendre un repos faire
des sondages d'opinion publique les
trucs et quand c'est nécessaire
m en fiche perforé la plupart des
problèmes de prospective et de marketing
ou donné des avis sur la marche d'une
société anonyme est licencié d'un seul
coup douze mille employés ou non du
rendement et de la rentabilité
on peut même lui apprendre à se tromper
régulièrement dans ses prévisions
concernant les guerres et les
révolutions mais on ne peut pas lui
apprendre à jouer aux échecs du moins
comme lui
et pourquoi
et tous forts en mathématiques je suis
instituteur ce n'est pas une réponse
je m'intéresse aux mathématiques alors
vous connaissez la formule permettant de
calculer les combinaisons possibles
compte tenu des 64 cases et les 32
pièces qui se meuvent de six manières
différentes
quand je dis je sais jouer cela signifie
mieux qu'un champion mais pas mieux que
lui pourquoi je n'ai pas été programmé
pour tricher et quand il le fait je ne
trouvent pas la parade et vous savez
vous jouez je joue très très mal vous
connaissez les pièces oui naturel
bien sûr pourriez vous l'aimez
le fou
un cavalier
[Musique]
le roi
la tour
la reine bien vous avez employé des mots
font cavalier roi tours et rennes n'est
ce pas ainsi qu'on doit les désigner
mais si mais si seulement vous allez
comprendre mon embarras s'il est
admissible que deux civilisations
différentes nez sur des planètes
différentes tournant autour d'un autre
soleil et même si tu es dans des
galaxies différentes et découvert
chacune de leur côté les délices subtil
du jeu d'échecs
en revanche il est hautement improbable
qu'elle ait choisi des mêmes symboles
pour personnaliser les pièces de ce jeu
or vous avez dit fou cavaliers ou à
tours et rennes
je dis ce que je voulais ce que vous
voyez ne peut se passer que sur terre et
vous qui avait été pêché par le chalut
vous prétendez venir de la terre
comprenez vous la contradiction
oui or mon cerveau a été sensibilisé
pour éliminer toutes les contradictions
vous ne croyez toujours pas que notre
planète s'appelle la terre mais si j'en
suis persuadé maintenant seulement la
terre du moins ce qu'il en reste après
l'explosion de l'ensemble la terre c'est
ici alors contradictions
et qui jouent cette partie le cerveau le
cerveau c'est la voix n'est ce pas celle
qui répète sans cesse mais si vraiment
vous ne nous apprennent rien oui c'est
le cerveau et peut-on le voir j'aime
bien voir le visage des gens qui me
parlent le visage le visage
m'est avis que vous allez être surpris
vous voulez le boire le voici
grâce à ceux-ci chacun et chacune est en
communication avec le cerveau ils
pensent coupe et connaissant leurs
désirs
il leur fabrique les images qu'ils
aiment recevoir et cela depuis des
siècles et des siècles
c'est pourquoi les être ici à force de
ne plus avoir besoin de leurs yeux les
ont perdus c'est une mutation biologique
classique
ils n'ont plus de bouche non plus
puisqu'ils n'ont plus jamais rien à
exprimer l'antenne transmets tout aux
hébreux pourquoi le cerveau joue t-il
aux échecs
parce que les autres ont besoin de jouer
regardez bien les pièces agir est ce le
cerveau qui les dirigent ou bien est-ce
leur volonté qu'elle impose au cerveau
temps l'estomac qui est un muscle a faim
il dit au cerveau débrouille toi j'ai
faim et le cerveau part en quête de
nourriture et coordonne les mouvements
du corps pour trouver cette nourriture
mais qui avait décidé qu'ils avaient
faim
lestement ou laisser le cerveau joue aux
échecs aussi parce que c'est un jeu
cérébral et qu'il tient à conserver son
agilité en vue de cette solution qu'il
n'a pas encore trouvé une solution
le soleil va mourir et il faut s'en
éloigner le cerveau ne sais pas comment
c'est pourquoi il cherchait il fait des
expériences
et ces êtres
tous reliés à ce cerveau qui leur
fabrique les images de leurs rêves ces
êtres qui sont ils mais des hommes pour
[Musique]
des hommes et des femmes
normal puisque nous sommes sur ce qui
reste de la terre après l'explosion de
lens en 1906 un calendrier il selon vous
en quelle année serions nous
actuellement
on l'en 5 millions 1972 après
jésus-christ comme on disait dans la
préhistoire à l'époque où les hommes et
les femmes avaient cinq doigts étaient
contraints de s'accoupler pour se
reproduire
bien avant l'explosion de la planète
bien avant
bien à vous
[Musique]
excuse moi plus tard le comprendrait
vous n'avez plus confiance en moi
une coccinelle
une bête à bon dieu votre bon dieu avoue
sera un robot chaque époque a les dieux
qu'elle mérite des dieux créé à son
image
tenez vous saurez les raisons que
j'avais de ne pas croire à votre
aventure
quand vous aurez vu ceci qui fait partie
de moi depuis plus de cinq millions
d'années
non regardez là je fonctionne très bien
sans ce sera à votre porte bonheur à
vous a tout de suite
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
je pense que miss aisne a voulu nous
montrer qu'ils avaient été fabriqués
avec certaines pièces en provenance de
la terre
qui seront terrien comme nous
naturellement vous voulez vous qu'elle
soit d'autre
et cela
baba
qui centimes
mais ça nous prétend que ce sont des
humains
[Musique]
décidément vous ne nous apprenez rien
décidément vous s'il s'agit d'êtres
humains ces massacres quelque chose
d'abominable il avait certainement
d'autres moyens
ce robinet culture interview on ne peut
tuer des êtres qui n'existeront que dans
5 millions d'années à moins que vous les
humains soyez assez insensé pour l'heure
donné naissance ces esclaves tous reliés
à un cerveau qui n'était en fait que le
reflet de leurs aspirations et de leurs
désirs défini par la statistique
c'est à dire soumis à la dictature de la
médiocrité
vous avez compris quelque chose je
saisis au passage les notions d'espacé
temps
mais le sens de la démonstration
m'échappe je reprends il suffit de
matérialiser l'espace par cette rangée
le temps par sept autres comme ceci
seulement si on ne dispose pas
convenablement les pièces le temps
devient l'espace et l'espace de l'union
le temps et quand on s'imaginait
d'explorer l'espace on explore le temps
il était parti à la conquête d'un autre
système solaire
parce que le soleil allait mourir c'est
cela est en réalité cet échiquier
ordinateur le démontre il ne faisait que
explorer leur propre passé
la voie est libre maintenant vous pouvez
retrouver votre monde avec son espace et
son temps quand vous voudrez cette fois
ci la démonstration était un peu plus
clair
un certain nombre de points cependant
est obscur et je me demande marianne le
temps l'espace les futurs terre possible
et leur virtuel habitants je m'en fous
vous comprenez je n'en pouvais m'en fous
je m'en fous je veux sortir des six mais
moi aussi
excusez-moi des explications viendront
plus tard si elle offre quelques
intérêts ce qu'il faut c'est sortir vous
comprenez sortie est sorti sortir voir
le fiel je suis hantée l'azur l'azur
l'azur mallarmé venez
allez
il suffit de passer le pont s'est tout
de suite laventure dire alors là la
tirelire a dit la radine l'homme tire a
dit de lala lala 20
[Musique]
alors c'est l'âme samedi paris d'une
aventure ah oui quelle aventure
quand on pense que dix minutes plus tôt
ou pas si elle colle sans histoire
tandis que là avec les congères qui
s'était formée des deux côtés vous étiez
comme qui dirait prisonniers oui c'est
bien cela patron nous étions prisonniers
est impossible de prévenir les ponts et
chaussées la tempête avait arraché les
fils téléphoniques
ça n'a pas dû être drôle de passer la
nuit dans la voiture
enfin quand je dis pas drôle
tout dépend 1 tout dépend comme vous
dites je parle je parle et vous devez
mourir de faim je vais vous pouvez
parier un solide casse croûte
en attendant si vous voulez un petit
coup de red pour vous réchauffer et
c'est la tournée du patron
non merci vous êtes très aimable je
préfère attendre le café et au jeune
homme je ne bois jamais d'alcool
maintenant sa valeur c'est là qu'il est
le meilleur
[Musique]
et